all right it's a major that's designed
to help students put together for
themselves a deep understanding of the
dynamics of power of how markets work
but then also to think about what to do
what is the right thing to do when one
has to make choices when their
trade-offs and so we're so delighted
today to have Wayne's Young I see that
he has a national following some of whom
are here today the students from Yale
are probably meeting Wayne and hearing
about him for the first time so you know
at the at the risk of repeating what
many of you know about him let me just
say a few things about him he is the
co-founder of direct action everywhere
and he's going to tell us about that
organization what he's doing and this
his activism which has exposed cruelty
and rescued animals and factory farms
has resulted in a terrorism
investigation by the FBI so that he's
currently facing 16 felony charges in
for criminal cases and will go on trial
this year depending on how the courts
decide to proceed and then of course
that also means it depends on the
pressure that the public puts on the
courts so that they would or would not
want to embarrass the judicial system if
the the public is very supportive of
what he's doing he's been featured in
Wired magazine in The New York Times in
the intercept some of you have seen
those pieces but let me tell you a
little bit about his intellectual
background for the Yale students here he
did a philosophy undergraduate degree at
University of Chicago he has a JD from
the University of Chicago he studied
economics at MIT in the ph.d program
and so he brings to bear on questions of
real importance of real ethical
importance the this deep intellectual
training and commitment as well so I
don't want to take any more of your
airtime this is a poster for you to take
home with you and thank you so much for
coming or really delighted thanks Jason
I actually came to Yale once before many
many years ago and it's always an honor
and really exciting to meet all the
students and hang out in New Haven
because it's a cool town I was gonna
tell you a little bit about what we do
but I thought instead of telling I just
show so I'm going to start out by just
showing a quick little video this is the
future and these people are seeing
everything to save it life is being
exterminated but the resistance is
growing our government has been
corrupted
our civilization is built on a lie
the truth is out there it's spreading
our eyes are opening
our hearts are burning getting ready for
direct action
[Music]
DNC activists are occupying
slaughterhouses worldwide we are
shutting down
massive factories abuse
we are taking back our democracy
[Music]
we are saving hundreds of animals and
this is their story
[Music]
the industry is hell-bent on stopping us
they've arrested hundreds of peaceful
activists but they can't stop the masked
man
[Music]
every voice they tried to silence is
joined by ten others
because we're bringing the fight
everywhere
from the courtroom to the front lawns
because our future depends on what we do
today because direct action is
everywhere everything
[Music]
to rescue
[Music]
for the animals this earth
[Music]
this is the fight of our lives
the future is in our and our voices are
rising
the entire cloth is moving the time for
change is now join us
I guess this is the first time most of
you heard from an alleged domestic
terrorist and you know I come to you as
a alleged domestic terrorist of many
apologies because I certainly have no
desire to be a domestic terrorist or an
alleged domestic terrorist I have no
desire to cause the West the FBI and
state and local law enforcement a waste
of millions of dollars they've wasted
hundred trying to put me in prison and I
wanted to show you this video first to
give you a sense of what we do what we
do and for the rest of the talk I want
to say something about why but before I
do that did everyone see Joaquin
Phoenix's Oscar acceptance speech
yesterday don't do that okay so if you
haven't seen it go check it out because
Joaquin put it in many ways more
eloquently than I can I'm going to show
you some science talk to you about some
sociology and political science but
Joaquin made a very simple point that at
the root of some of the evils we face on
this planet today is our disconnect from
the natural world our disconnect from
each other from our communities from the
plants and the non-human animals who
share this earth with us and that
disconnection has led to systematic
slaughter destruction and violence on a
scale never before seen in history and
that is why I've done what I've done
over the past couple of years and that
is why I'm facing the federal charges
the state charges the federal
investigations the state investigations
I'm facing today so the plan for the
talk is pretty simple I'm not going to
talk to you long this is a fairly small
group so if you have a clarifying
question feel free to jump in raise your
hand I'm happy to answer any questions
we'll have some time after it's because
I'm hoping to talk for just about 20
minutes or so about why if we are
serious about frankly not just climate
justice but social justice we absolutely
have to include animal rights in the
three reasons are set out right here and
I came up with some kind of useful
mnemonic devices to think about these
things but there there are three values
that animal rights provides even a human
rights activist that we really have to
understand if we want to get serious
about climate justice and social justice
in this country and the first is
diagnostic value that we need to
consider animal rights because what
happens the animals will happen to us
they are the Canaries in the climate
mine the second is the NMR to actually
provides immense instrumental value to
human populations and human
civilizations and we eat our dead they
come
back to haunt us and third and finally
the animal rights movement has intrinsic
value animals are their own they have
feelings of pain and pleasure they have
families just like us and there are
subjects of justice just like any
marginalized community and so if we want
to really have a just community if we
believe our society is a just society we
have to impose what I call a political
stress test on our institutions and
tests how are the most marginalised
being treated because after all the test
of justice not is not how the powerful
and the wealthy are treated in every
society history even dictatorships and
kleptocracy so the powerful and wealthy
are treated with decency the test of a
good political institution of a good
political system is one where the
marginalized are treated with respect so
let's jump in to the first but let me
actually say some more about the nature
of the problem we face and I'm gonna
show you some videos that explain the
intersection between climate justice and
animal rights because while we all
understand and in the City of Berkeley
where I'm from we've now declared a
climate crisis most folks don't know
about the nonhuman victims of this
crisis I'm going to show you some photos
and videos that demonstrate these
non-human victims I'm gonna warn you
ahead of time some of the photos and
videos I'm going to show you during this
talk will be a little bit distressing so
as a trigger warning if you need to step
out you're seeing animals in some degree
of distress I'm not going to show you
anything too gruesome or awful but I
will show you some sad scenes of what's
happened in animals across our entire
planet because their climate change okay
so here's the first video so this is a
recent video that national grief that
graphic shared an increasingly common
video of a polar bear mother in her cub
and polar bears photos you don't know
have lived in the Arctic for millions of
years but over the last 30 to 40 years
all the food is disappearing because the
ice is disappearing they can no longer
find a place to hunt and find food so
for the first time in history I'm
actually going to pause it real quick
polar bear mothers have been forced to
go after prey that are not natural price
so a walrus is a 1,300 to up to 3,000
pound animal a polar bear mother is
about 500 pound animals and what it
colleges have found when they're out
there in the Arctic is they see these
polar bears actually trying to attack
animals that are far larger than that
they should not be trying to consume so
what happens is when these polar bears
are not finding
Arctic sea ice where they historically
found Arctic sea ice they just keep
swimming in swimming they have to go
further and further north further inform
earth because where they usually give
birth to their babies as in these
southern dens these warmer places and
then they go north to hunt and their
babies will fall behind them but as
they're swimming up they're seeing
scenes like this unfold across the
Arctic and I'll just show you this scene
too so one recent study found that as
Arctic sea ice disappears when they have
put collars on polar bear mothers who
are going into areas where Arctic sea
ice started to disappear sometimes these
polar bears are being forced to swim 400
miles over nine days because they keep
swimming expecting to find ice the ice
never appears and one study found that
half of polar bear cubs in these low ice
regions are drowning to death and when
the mothers arrive at the northern
places their babies have all died they
are starving to death because they've
been swimming for nine days non-stop and
they arrive at land that has no more
food left so this is another scene from
National Geographic and all these poor
polar bears have left to feed on in some
cases is just garbage so polar bears are
just one of 1 million to say liyan 1
million species they'll be gone from the
face of the planet earth over the next
generation if we don't do something
about climate change in habitat
destruction and while polar bears are
the charismatic megafauna and obviously
we care about Koller bears it's
important to note that there's so many
other ways climate change is decimating
non-human animals does anyone know what
the most numerous vertebrate animal on
the face of the earth is this picture
should give you a little bit of a hint
the most numerous vertebrate animal
insects of the most numerous animals and
I think ants are by biomass one of the
dominant species on this planet any
guesses close it's a little bit bigger
than a krill krill are sometimes so
small that they're almost microscopic
this is similar to krill it's it this
this species of animal actually feeds on
krill any guesses as to what this is so
it's actually probably the dominant
animal in our ocean ecosystem and by
biomass for those you don't know aquatic
ecosystems comprise about 99 percent of
the biome of Earth 70% of the surface
area of the planet Earth is
Oshin and because the ocean goes deep
it's on the land there's only one level
right there's only one plane for land
well the ocean actually has it's almost
like there's there's ten Earth's layered
on top of each other because you have
the liminal state you have the mid water
you have the deep water all these
different States and this is a deep
water mid water deep water sea fish
called the bristle mouth fish and
ecologists have found surprisingly to
many that the the bristle mouth fish
dominates pretty much all species of
animals possibly combined they're
anywhere from 1 trillion to one trillion
or I'm sorry 100 trillion to 100
quadrillion bristle mouths fish all over
the oceans and the reason we started
realizing this was because when we
started doing deep-sea dredging for
fishing which is these huge kind of like
shovel like devices where they just take
everything in an entire ocean ecosystem
and try and get the 5 or 6 species of
fish that we want to eat and you've
probably heard about all the other
animals get swept up whether they find
over and over again is these bristle
male fish which are these little cute
you know finger length fish that have
bristles as mouths you can imagine them
being like a swimming toothbrush if
you've ever had one of those hotel
toothbrushes they're about that big
right they've got little bristles at the
end they're very cute animals and
they're translucent skin because in the
deep there there's really no need for
their skin to block sun radiation
because there's no Sun they're in the
deep well what what scientists and
ecologist have found is over the past 10
to 20 years partly because of the
thermohaline process that I just
described the ocean waters are no longer
sinking because they're warm and warm
water rises cold water sinks there's no
more oxygen in the deep and what that
means is the hundreds of trillions are
hundreds of quadrillion Bristol mouths
fish can no longer breathe they're
literally suffocating and what they do
instead when the oxygen dissolved oxygen
in the ocean because the ocean water is
no longer sinking sinking is not coming
to them is they go to the top they keep
swimming to the top and they're all
crowding at the liminal states that the
top layers of the ocean so you've
probably all seen one of these kind of
campy horror movies where someone's
trapped in a room and the water rises
right and it's like it's kind of a scary
scene it's like oh my gosh I'm chopping
this room and I'm flying in the water
keeps rising this is what's literally
happening to quadrillions of animals so
that's like you know quadrillions ten a
hundred thousand a million times more
individuals than the entire key
race combined more human beings more
more animals than have then then have
existed then human beings have existed
on the face the planet Earth and all of
the Earth's history
are all rushing to the top layers of the
ocean because they can no longer breathe
and they're suffocating to death this is
just one scene of the sorts of things
we're going to start seeing much more
often of literally billions quadrillions
of fish being shoved to the top layers
of the ocean and dying this specific
image is actually because of an algae
bloom which is a very similar phenomenon
where all the oxygen of the ocean
disappears the fish rush to the top to
try and get close to these top layers so
they can get some oxygen but most of
them just die off okay and then finally
the New York Times actually just wrote
about this everyone's favorite animal
the platypus when I was a little kid I
loved the flavus so over the past few
years we've seen that because of all the
the heat and the wind and the
dehydration that's being caused by
climate change the ponds these are
aquatic animals like again most of the
animals in the search are aquatic
animals because the heat is causing all
the ponds and streams to dry up
there's just muddy slop left these poor
platypuses that have lived in these
aquatic ecosystems sometimes for
hundreds of thousands millions of years
no longer have any water left they're
slopping around in mud which means they
starve to death because all all the food
they normally would eat would come from
an aquatic ecosystem which doesn't exist
and so you've got these platypuses
traveling many miles and they don't walk
very well trying to find water somewhere
instead they usually will slowly starve
to death be hit by a car or be predated
on by a cat a fox or some of the animal
scientists have found that over the past
couple decades 41% of the range
historically that had platypuses no
longer has platypuses they're all gone
because it's all drying up due to
climate change so cute ugly one million
species as I said arguing extinct due to
habitat loss and climate change this
number continues to go up we are facing
the sixth mass extinction crisis on the
planet Earth but many folks will even
see these cute images and say well why
does this really matter I mean let's get
serious
platypuses or cue polar bears are cute
but at the end of the day you know
there's still not human beings they're
not us right so why should we get
serious about this and why should we do
things like what I've done which is to
challenge factory farms
and environment destructive corporations
to the point that I'm risking 16 felony
charges and the rest of my life in
prison
in fact one very prominent economist
maybe the most prominent climate
economist actually any guesses as to
whom the most prominent climate
economist in the world is no he's not an
economist he's a linguist Nordhaus who's
bill Morehouse who said that who's bill
Morehouse you want to say William
Nordhaus but who is he yeah he yeah so
he invited he invented a system called
dice it's kind of a program to
understand I think it's dynamic
interrelated climate and I forget what
the e stands for so I don't even
remember but he won the Nobel Prize in
2018 because he's he's one of the most
serious economists on the issue of
climate change and the Nobel Committee
awarded him this Nobel Prize because he
was taking a lot of time and effort to
trying to understand how human beings
can adapt to all the destruction and
devastation caused by climate change and
he's done good work in understanding how
climate changes can affect everything
from Bangladeshis whose homes are being
flooded now to you know Americans living
in New Haven who might have more extreme
weather and tried to like understand
economically what are the impacts going
to be sociologically what are the
impacts going to be on human
civilization and again his work is so
renowned it won him a Nobel Prize and
you should go take a class with him but
Bill North House has a little bit of a
problem in his model and I've pointed
this out since 2006 when I first
published a paper on this subject and
the University of Pennsylvania Law
Review and that is and actually let me
just ask you I've just talked to you
about some of the impacts of climate
change on non-human animals on natural
systems so when you look at Bill nor
houses models anyone want to give a
guess as to if if bill Mart House uses
his dice model and estimates how much
money we should spend in protecting
non-human animals what is the cost of
climate change to all these non-human
animals than 1 million species that are
going extinct what is the number the
figure that bill Nordhaus says we should
be spending to protect all these animals
just throw it out there zero yeah so in
a book that he wrote in 2000 he said
that the impacts on non-human animals
and natural systems are too small or
uncertain to be mad
so therefore our models are just going
to exclude them entirely and the same
has been true of the IPCC the World
Health Organization the United Nations
over and over again we find that the by
far the most numerous victims of climate
change are being completely ignored so
as I said I think this is a farce and I
think that even if you look at things
from a humano centric perspective in
other words from the perspective of
human civilization we need to get
serious about animal rights but we also
need to think about intrinsically what
obligations we have to the natural world
- the other one happened into this earth
and the first reason is because of the
diagnostic value of animal rights this
is an image from Indonesia has anyone
heard about what's happening to rang at
Ang's Indonesia yeah so its annihilation
so there's been a decline of about a
hundred thousand their populations
there's estimates range from a few
thousand to maybe tens of thousands left
they only exist in two different islands
I mean very large islands Sumatra and
Borneo and Indonesia a beautiful species
of incredibly compassionate animals
there they're wonderful they they don't
harm anyone they do harm each other but
you can go and watch them and they won't
attack a human being so they're gentle
giants and they're being exterminated
and one of the reasons is palm oil
plantations which you've probably heard
about but another big reason is is what
any guesses I'll give you a hint what's
happened in Australia recently fires
right and those fires are caused by
climate change there's been massive
change in extreme weather events dessa
fication of the entire ecosystem there's
so much dry dry areas like where this
baby orangutan is standing where there
used to be all sorts of vibrant foliage
and and in flora and fauna that would
prevent a wildfire from erupting and
wildfires and won the big culprits that
have driven orangutangs nearly to
extinction in fact a 2007 report
indicated that much of this much of
these wildfires were almost directly
related to increasing temperatures in
droughts that prevented normal ecosystem
practices that would prevent wildfires
from spending to broadly from causing
Borneo and Sumatra to burn to a crisp
well what happened to Iranian teens in
2007 if we had been paying attention to
it 10 years ago would have predicted
what's happening in California today and
this is an image from California in 2018
for those of you who don't follow what's
happening California there have been
massive wild
in both northern and southern california
with exactly the same characteristics
high winds very dry weather drought for
long periods of time that lead almost
any spark from a power line to cause a
raging blaze and in fact in 2018 alone 2
million acres of land burned to a crisp
exactly like this their 100-plus
fatalities and hundreds of thousands of
people were displaced hundreds of
thousands of people had to leave so 10
years ago it was happening the rang
attains last year was happening in fact
Lee this year too because I was
mentioning to many of you the 2010 19
wildfires only burned only burned burned
300,000 acres instead of to 2 million
acres but that came at a steep cost too
because the only reason we didn't have
wildfires was because PG&E just shut the
power off we didn't have power for about
a week ok so another example of the
Canaries in the climate mine anyone
heard of the Kitteridge fungus any
biologists in the room okay so the
kitchener fungus is a fungus that has
been spreading to in fib Ian's around
the world and one genesis of frog called
a hollow cone frogs there have been
something like 67 out of hundred and ten
species have gone extinct over the past
few decades and this fungus is a fungus
that grows in warm moist conditions
there's some evidence that when there's
a lot of climate stress being imposed on
the animals higher temperatures these
animals are more prone to the infection
and what happens with the kitchen fungus
is it gets into the frogs teeth and
their skin it just slowly eats them away
so you may have heard about men eating
bacteria this is a frog eating fungus
and it's causing amphibians across the
world to go extinct so in 2006 there's a
patriot paper in nature basically saying
that climate change was one of the main
culprits and while there's some debate
about how much climate change has caused
the growth of the kidron fungus there's
no question that climatic conditions
have at least cause more stress to the
animals which leads them more prone to
being affected by the fungus well guess
what happened just last year at Stanford
a study was done by Aaron
Mordecai at Stanford University at the
medical school showing that climate
change is causing higher disease rates
in human beings to the literal quote is
it's coming for you and Aaron was not
talking about people in sub-saharan
Africa we probably heard about Deng
fever
you know malaria the the corona virus in
China she was talking about people in
North America because as climatic
conditions change as we have higher temp
across the previously more temperate
regions of the earth mosquitoes go all
over the world disease and pathogens
that previously were not able to
reproduce as rapidly and as effectively
as they are today are increasing and the
w-h-o now estimates that within the next
few decades we could see a 300 thousand
person 3,000 an increase in 300,000 or
the number of deaths due to infectious
disease due to climate change so again
in 2006 we were talking about the frogs
in 2019 we're talking about us literally
in this community here today and the
coronavirus for this you know know came
from a wild animal market it came from
our exploitation of animals or at least
that's our best estimate according to
the Centers for Disease Control okay
so again what's happening to the animals
this earth might not seem like a big
deal but these are the Canaries in the
climate mine if we don't be mindful of
what happens the other inhabitants of
this earth we're all part of the same
genealogical web it's not a chain it's
not a hierarchy it's a web of life and
when the other life on this earth is
dying
it is a preview of what's going to
happen to us if we don't change now
let's move on to the second point eating
our dead the instrumental value of the
Android statement does anyone know what
this is a scene of sad and distressing
okay it's a hurricane and the flood
caused by hurricane and this is actually
not hurricane Florence although there
were many scenes like this from
Hurricane Florence the pork industry in
the pig farming industry was smart
enough to realize it couldn't allow
these sorts of things to happen so they
didn't allow as many of these images
that come out this is actually a scene
from Hurricane Floyd in 1999 when there
was not a much as much awareness about
factory farms but what happened with
hurricane Florence is the client you
know with climate change causing more
extreme weather events like hurricanes
there is mass flooding and huge pig
farms there are tens of millions of pigs
who are raised and slaughtered for food
in North Carolina the flood levels rose
and these pigs literally had nowhere to
go in some cases drowned in their barns
in some cases you know got outside or
even standing on roof desperately hoping
for someone to come rescue them
and there's many many problems with this
first of all the number of pigs in North
Carolina is far smaller than the number
of human beings but because pigs produce
so much waste and it's so concentrated
cumulative Lee pig farming in North
Carolina creats 10 billion with a B
gallons of waste every year
and massive Aniela goons and the
floodwaters came in these manure lagoons
which are filled with chemicals
antibiotics diseased decomposing corpses
of animals flooded the entire region of
North Carolina and of course it'sa
communities of color lived next to these
farms are most adversely affected you
also probably know or you might have
heard that all the waste from these
farms and from feed Lots that raise
cattle for both milk and for me creates
a huge amount of methane and methane is
28 times more powerful as a greenhouse
gas and carbon dioxide estimates range
from 10 to 51 percent of all greenhouse
gases produced by the United States are
coming directly from feed Lots like this
one and then finally of course is
antibiotic resistant diseases 70 percent
of all human grade antibiotics in this
country are being fed to farm animals
these farm animals are growing superbugs
within their bodies that then jump to us
and kill us and the coronal virus is a
great example this the CDC says that
that the best the best hypothesis as to
where the corona virus came which is
killed I think close to a thousand
people now and could cause a great
global pandemic similar to the flu
epidemic in the early 20th century is a
wild animal marketing a live animal
market in muhan China because all the
first cluster of people who came down to
the coronavirus it all came from this
wild animal market may have come from a
bat may have come from another animal
they eats all sorts of animals
unfortunately in these live animal
markets and I like to call this zombie
capitalism that we turned these living
creatures into corpses those corpses
come back to haunt us they haunt us by
destroying our environment they haunt us
by destroying our water and our air and
they haunt us by literally destroying
our own bodies because the diseases that
are killing them will eventually kill us
but it's not just that harming animals
and ignoring the harm were causing
animals hurts us it's that human beings
it turns out really really value for our
own sake what's happened to animals
anyone know who this is any guesses
sessile the line so anyone remember us
on the line remember this from 2015
okay so suss of the line was a beloved
lion in a wildlife animal park who was
not supposed to be hunted and he wasn't
fortunately hunted a hunter hit him with
a crossbow
sessile ran away with the crossbow on
his shoulder and slowly bled out over 12
hours and died a torturous Lee painful
death and sessile the lion well you know
you hear people all the time say oh
forget about
people don't care about animals and
politicians say this all the time my
politicians always telling me I'm going
to knocking on their doors begging them
to take some action about factory farms
about the abusive animals in the
environment they say people don't care
about animals at all well it turns out
sussel lion was one of the biggest news
events may be at the decade in a single
day there were 12,000 this is just a
single day 12,000 mainstream media
articles about Cecil the lion 700,000
social media postings and when Jimmy
Kimmel cried about sussel lion on
national television within a few hours
150,000 dollars of enraged to support
wildlife conservation in Africa it turns
out the US government also already
accepts that animals matter to some
extent we have a law on the books called
the Endangered Species Act that is run
by a group of lawyers called the God
Squad where we literally spend billions
of dollars protecting endangered species
already so if we just took the amount of
money we're currently using to protect
animals and endangered species if we
took the amount of money that people are
currently donating to protect animals in
the environment for animals and we just
projected that out in a linear
trajectory over the next thirty years
both with the quantity of animals that
are suffering and dying the number of
species that are going extinct that
means we should increase the amount of
spending and the amount of resource
mobilization to protect animals and
wildlife and species by like a thousand
fold right so even if only all you care
about is how much human beings care
about animals it turns out we need
invest like a thousandfold more
resources and in protecting natural
systems from devastation like this okay
but third and finally is the intrinsic
value of animals and this is the most
important point I want to leave you with
um so does everyone remember the
financial crisis in 2008 probably most
of you I guess some of the younger
students might remember anyone not
remember the financial crisis of 2008
nearly brought down the entire global
economy okay so who remembers and who
feels like you have a good understanding
of what happened there okay you sound
like so tell us what happened what was
the cause of the financial crisis in a
few sentences
oh maybe I can build it you get
something wrong I'll fill it at home
where it's upright more disagreement
ought to be questioned no I have had
that would not just be a qualified for
mortgages and then when this no I'm
sorry correct it yeah I think that's
right yeah so what happened is there is
kind of a nationwide decline in home
prices triggered in part by bad lending
like banks have been offering everyone
lots of money to buy whatever homes and
often using these kind of fancy subprime
mortgages that had teaser rate so we're
doing things basically tricked people
into buying homes that they could not
actually afford right and what happened
when there was a nationwide decline and
mortgage prices and everyone realized oh
my gosh all these homes are going down
all these borrowers cannot pay off their
loans there was a bank run effectively
everyone was selling off all these
assets they're going to their bank and
saying I want out and that caused a
financial collapse and nearly brought
down the entire global economy okay so
let's talk about this this is just an
example so let's talk about this after
the talk in the Q&A okay great it's a
great point but let's talk about it
afterwards so what what what economics
experts designed after the 2008 time
period is something called a financial
stress test and the idea is if our
economic system is actually a good
economic system we cannot allow things
like that to happen again we can't have
decline in one asset by five ten fifteen
percent cause a global cascade that
destroys the entire economy of the globe
and they designed what are called
financial stress tests which are
basically tests where you look at some
possible bad scenarios and you see how
the economic system does and they even
did this on a bank by bank basis they
went to all the big big banks and said
okay let's say your assets declined by 5
or 10 percent or 5 or 10% of your
depositors come forward and say I went
out cash me out you need to be able to
prove you can survive that that your
economic system actually works in that
worst-case scenario because that
scenario is going to happen right so the
argument I want to make today is that we
think about both the human and the
nonhuman victims of climate change that
are not the most powerful and wealthy
victims of climate change and I mean
people in Bangladesh who 70% of the
nation's land is now underwater 18
million people will soon be homeless
because the saltwater is flooding their
land they can no longer grow crops and
eternal and live on this land because
they live in a low sea-level area of
Southeast Asia we think about the polar
bears of this earth who have no
political power who have no money who
have no ability to fight and protest if
climate change policies are enacted we
need to think about our political
institutions as surviving a stress test
and as I said at the start this talk the
ultimate test of whether a political
system is just is how does it treat
those without power how does it treat
those without wealth because every
political system can survive the stress
of the powerful asking for justice
the powerful always treated fairly
because they have power right but the
definition of justice is a system that
treats those with no power as if they're
deserving of respect so when we think
about climate change instead of thinking
about how much does it cost a
corporation like Amazon or corporation
like Exxon we should think about how
much it's gonna cost the Bangladeshi
child who might have to live at a
garbage dump in a congested urban area
in Bangladesh because their home and
their village ancestral homeland that
they've lived in perhaps for thousands
of years it's now under water we should
think about the polar bear mother who
after swimming for days and watching all
of her babies die off arrives in the
Arctic region sees no food available to
her and sometime in the next few decades
one of these polar bear mothers will
swim up to the Arctic look around
realize she has never seen she's not
seeing another polar bear in years
she left her dead head down on the
ground and realized that this is the
last polar bear on the face of the earth
if we want to prove that our political
system is actually just not just for
these marginalized peoples and for these
marginalized animals but even for us we
have to have a political stress test
that proves out the concept that our
institutions are robust to even
situations where the person being harmed
or the animal being harmed has no
ability to fight back because after all
at any point it could be one of us it
could be the Chinese kid who's on the
other end of the system it could be the
Jewish kid it could be the immigrant
from France any of us could be on the
other end of that system if we don't
prove that our system is robust enough
that the the notion of equality and fair
play and respect for all sentient life
has not infused itself into the code the
political DNA of our society to the
point that
knows about power are being protected
then our system can be used against
anyone in a corrupt and oppressive way
so what does this all mean concretely
I'm gonna give you an example from a
specific location that's actually just a
few blocks from my house this is Golden
Gate fields and many of you know that in
the Bay Area and frankly around the
nation we have a housing crisis the
average apartment is $3,000 homelessness
is increased by 42 percent over the last
three years we now have thousands of
people living in homeless encampments
and this is an older image but if this
were a more recent image you'd actually
see a bunch of tents lining up or under
the highway because when someone is
kicked out of their home and no longer
can afford an apartment and a roof over
their head the place that you usually
will try and live is in these under
passes because when the rain comes down
they at least have some shelter for
themselves so this is an image from a
few days ago so if you went here today
at Golden Gate Fields you'd see tents
lining the highway underneath the
highway and increases of 42 percent over
the past couple years you'd see RVs
along the side of the streets because a
lot of people are losing their homes are
moving to RVs and over here at Golden
Gate fields you see millionaires in
billionaires drinking lots of wine
racing horses of death in a circle over
and over again so what I want to do is
do kind of a little political analysis
let's do a political stress test of
Golden Gate fields and ask ourselves how
various individuals who are living here
and actually going to Golden Gate fields
and these are all real-world examples
many cases they're people I actually
know and how our political system works
at these people along three different
dimensions one is how much of the
problem are these people causing right
in terms of climate devastation income
inequality pollution to the air and the
water how much is being contributed by
by this particular individual second how
much do they have to contribute to solve
the problem and third how much is our
society and our government asking them
to contribute okay so let's start with a
billionaire there's a lot of
billionaires in the Bay Area you know I
I live near some billionaires
surprisingly not back close because I
live in the poor area but neighborhood
of Berkeley but if you go 15 minutes
away 10 minutes away in the Berkeley
Hills they're billionaires in fact the
Bay Area has more billionaires than
anywhere in the world there's so many
billionaires
lottie's billionaires actually have
multiple homes some of them even have
homes in Berkeley in San Francisco even
though it's only about 25 30 minutes
away gonna have a mansion in Berkeley
and a mansion in San Francisco and a lot
of these billionaires also travel around
the world you know therefore
New York City London they often have a
home in New York City in the Bay Area
and Beijing all sorts of places and it
turns out these billionaires did a very
good job of a political lobbying back in
the 80s and 90s and there's a law in the
books that says capital appreciation of
real estate investments is never text so
this billionaire flies into Berkeley use
this enormous amount of fossil fuels and
emits huge numbers of greenhouse gas
sixes flying is very destructive the
climate in the environment lives in an
extremely large home in Berkeley that
when you heat it or cool it or even just
provide electricity it uses a huge
number of greenhouse gases and when his
the value of his property appreciates
say by 10 million dollars so he's got a
couple homes how much do you think of
that is taxed well I've already told you
it's zero there's there's no taxation on
that at all so the the billionaires
contributing a high level to the
environmental devastation in human and
non-human suffering has ten million
dollars that he hasn't worked for it's
just kind of real-estate speculation the
value of the property has gone up he's
just sat in his offices or flown back
and forth between London and the Bay
Area and he has ten million dollars of
real money that he could use I could go
to anything in our society and he pays
exactly zero dollars in taxes so it's
moved to the second person so I told you
there's the billionaires who are sitting
in the Golden Gate Fields watching the
horses race each other to death there
actually have been dozens of horses that
have died in the tracks for the record
so it's a cruel facility as well there's
a houseless resident across the street
someone who was a dog walker who got
kicked out of their apartment because
rentals got so high they could no longer
live in their apartment and you know
when the average apartment is $3,000 a
month a lot of people are kicked out of
their apartments are evicted permanently
this person can all afford a home in
Berkeley even though they lived there
their entire lives and they're
continuing to walk dogs but they had to
just hit put it put up a tent on the
side of the street right outside a
Golden Gate Fields underneath the high
behind your pass they use basically no
greenhouse gases because they can't
afford a flight they don't have a home
so they have no heating or cooling cost
they'd have a car so there's no fossil
fuels from their transit they do
contribute a little because they hop on
a bus in a train to get all their dog
walking gigs and again I know people
like this I know people who were dog
walkers who lost their homes and are now
living on the streets this house this
person is earning $10,000 by walking 20
dogs a week
for $10 a walk which is actually a lot
of work walking 20 dogs a week is anyone
walked a lot of dogs before it's not
easy to walk one dog walking 20 dogs a
week is actually lot of work and it's an
important service like I have dogs it's
actually really important to me that
someone walks my dogs if not me
somebody's got to walk my dogs so
they're doing good hard work they're
earning $10,000 a year from walking 20
dogs a week at $10 for a walk and their
tax rate is what do you think they pay
in taxes how much are they paying the
billionaire paid zero dollars on a ten
million dollar increase in wealth how
much do you think they're paying he
knows the tax system 15 percent so
they're paying about 1500 dogs because
the Social Security Medicare taxes if
you're part of the gig economy which you
know increasingly young people like you
can't get jobs and real corporations
because the corporations are using
robots or you know people from around
the world can can automate away your job
so you're self-employed you're an
impending contractor so you're paying
your full 15 percent labor tax which is
what this dog walker has to do so the
billionaire is paying less taxes both in
terms of total amount and in terms of
the amount that the percentage amount
then the homeless person across the
street from Golden Gate fields
okay and the fine let's think about the
horse so horses in racing tracks spend
about 23 hours out of 24 hours out of
every day living in a stall basically
small as their own body they come out
for one hour a day where they're beaten
and injected with drugs non-consensual E
many of them died because whenever
there's an accident and they break down
they euthanize them and you may have
heard about this in the media that there
been dozens of horses killed at Santa
Anita going gate fields and Berkeley is
owned by the same company and there was
a horse who died just a few weeks ago
and a racing accident this horse does
not use any fossil fuels at all because
he's a horse he's not using fossil fuels
he just sits in his little stall all day
so he's contributing basically nothing
to the problem of environmental
devastation and climate change and the
fruit of his labor
you know if he's unless he's a famous
worse he's probably about $1,000 and and
by the end of the year that thousand
dollars probably includes the sale price
of the horse when his body breaks down
and horses in racing they'll break down
after a few years so you know normally
would probably lessen this but let's say
he sold off to a stockyard at the end of
the year where incidentally many of
these horses and then shipped to places
like Canada and Mexico and slaughtered
in fact shockingly I didn't even learn
this in
I started preparing these slides there
was a winner of the Kentucky Derby in
1986 Ferdinand who went on to make
millions of dollars for his owners he
was then killed in a Japanese
slaughterhouse in 1995 nine years later
and sold off for me possibly for pet
food so this horse is earning a thousand
dollars for our society that could be
used as something because you know
they're people gambling coming and
buying tickets and billionaires are
coming and watching him run around in a
circle and then when his body is sold
off you know he might be sold for $500
$400 and then shipped off to Canada to
be slaughtered for people in France to
eat um how much is society taking from
him well they're taking everything right
that horse none of that money that he's
generating know that labor goes back to
him when his owner decides you know what
you're no longer working out for me I'm
sending you off to Japan to be eaten or
to France to be slaughtered that horse
gets nothing and again as I said even
some of the most famous horses in
history like Ferdinand who won the
Kentucky Derby in 1986 were shipped off
to slaughter when they were no longer
used to when they're too old to stud or
to race they're killed and eaten because
their owners could make some money okay
so what we're saying is our political
institution is failing the political
stress test right by any definition of
justice those who are contributing the
least of the problem and have the least
to offer are being asked for the most
like these horses the homeless person is
paying a higher tax rate than the
billionaire the horse gets nothing at
all as a billionaire is watching him run
around in a circle and so what I think
we need to is invert that right and this
is what we call the green new city and
obviously running for mayor of Berkeley
on this platform are trying to invert
the dynamic that we've seen for too long
in our society and give those who have
the most and are causing the most a fair
part of that burden and the thing is
even billionaires when you actually talk
to them about these specific examples
they recognize yeah this isn't fair and
we have to do is talk about this more
often because too for too long electoral
politics in this country have been
controlled by the wealthy or the
powerful by the people of the time and
the influence and the resources and the
connections to make change happen for
their class and we want need is not a
system that just serves the few but a
system that serves all because that by
by definition a just system is one where
the powerless are protected so in this
green new city which I'm calling triple
up climate justice and I think I'm
borrowing this from other folks who've
coined this term this is a carbon
positive plant-based City by 2025 one
that starts by divesting taxpayer
resources from wealthy industries like
fossil fuels animal AG the restaurant
industry and instead announcing the the
creation of a green district that is
completely pedestrian where public
transit is free where we have solar
panels instead of roads and where every
single resident of Berkeley is given a
one thousand dollar green dividend to
invest in this district right that I
don't care if you're a houseless person
on the street or you're billionaire in
the hills
everybody's gonna share in the benefits
of this district if you cause a problem
you chip in a little more and if you
don't have much to give we give you a
little bit more back so if we can create
this sort of district the goal and the
vision is not just to create one green
city but it's a soul the National
paralysis we're currently seeing and
whether you like Bernie Sanders or lives
us more or frankly even Donald Trump
we're not going to get this done at the
national level this rectification of our
political injustice is of our economic
injustice is not going to happen at the
national level because at the end of the
day national politics depends too much
on big institutions that are too slow to
change and if we are facing a crisis if
a million species arguing exceeds
homeless people don't have food on their
plates
our roofs over their heads and it
actually is a crisis we can't set
timelines of 2035 2045 or 2050 we have
to do this now and that means taking
urgent bold action to address this
crisis in at least one city and if we
can do it in one city and one of the
reasons I moved to Berkeley is because
Berkeley has led the nation in so many
different social and political and
economic areas Berkeley is a city filled
with progressives and liberals and
hippies who are willing to experiment if
we can prove out the concept in one city
and say in one city we can have green
housing for everyone green food for
every family and a green dividend for
the future instead of subsidies for
billionaires then we can say to the rest
of the state the rest of the nation in
frankly the rest of the world that
carbon neutrality climate justice animal
justice is actually possible so that's
when I'll end you with this is not an
experiment that's only going to happen
in Berkeley it's going to experiment
that will unfold in other cities across
the nation there are other cities like
Cort Eva Brazil they're also trying
experiments like this and we have to
recognize is if we don't change our
local City Councils
our boards of Supervisors are
streets and communities we're not gonna
be able change national politics so as
much as it's exciting to listen to what
Bernie has to say what Elizabeth has to
say and maybe even what Donnell has to
say sometimes it's much more important
for you to find out what your local
supervisor has the same what you
personally can do to change your
community so let's get out there and
let's try and do something about this
thank you all very much for listening to
me and I can take some questions so
questions critiques thoughts yeah I do
want to start off by saying my family
has a long history of fighting injustice
so probably pretty hairy
so my Roberta Leland my dad was a
professor here plant physiologist or
environmental science school I had a lot
of vegan friends yeah we swing the
pendulum back and forth on environmental
issues and I'm a reductionist I'm not a
vegan but I can see being a vegetarian
although it's a lot of work but since I
aged 16 I've always thought eggs are the
way to rescue poverty in the third world
and poor you know nutrition yeah that
you can get somebody even marginally
living and it's not too hard to raise
chickens yeah and eggs are just like
excellent protein source sure
so I'm an advocate for animal rights but
I also point out and I know a lot of
people may think I'm a little crazy but
plants have a consciousness - yeah you
know so I can't see
you're always say yeah to my vegan
friends you know the broccolis scream
when you picked them because you know
give him the chance to flower yeah you
know and and so I do think that there's
an energy there that we're working with
should be versed and and may have had
this amazing relationship with bovines
4000 a couple thousand years that got us
through the Ice Age but we've now
reached the point where maybe you can
leave note behind it along not really
I'm kind of against milk but for yogurt
Sarah everybody's got a little bit of a
different gut yeah and and we've got to
work on moving in the correct direction
yeah he's amazing something exactly
fossil fuels and climate change I mean
you said yeah the horse doesn't
contribute anything but he does
contribute nothing else to the horses do
when they breathe carbon dioxide so we
do in the same way right so you're right
it's not zero so I think your point is
well-taken so and if you look at kind of
the environmental impacts of various
industries the egg industry in the
poultry industry are much less
devastating than then we're in the
ranching industry so for example the
Amazon wildfires primarily caused by
cattle ranching not by poultry farms or
by ugh farms nonetheless there's a basic
kind of physical reason that anytime you
move through trophic levels and feed all
these plants animals and then convert
that into whether its eggs are flesh
you're going to lose lots of energy and
so even the most efficient animal
products which are chickens are I think
it was David Pimentel the Cornell
University who did the analysis on this
about 1/8 as efficient as plant-based
foods at the same time right so you're
talking about you're losing 70 80
percent of the potential energy that you
could be feeding directly to human
beings to the animals who then convert
into energy that we eat but the second
point I make is the last point of this
presentation which is that the problem
of using eggs isn't just the immediate
impacts the instrumental impacts on
human beings it's the notion that we can
use other beings for our profit right
and if we're going to feed 7 billion
human beings eggs and give them enough
protein inevitably we're gonna put lots
of those beings in cages we're going to
put them in factory farms because there
isn't enough land on this earth to house
all these chickens if we don't
put them in factory forms these chickens
don't have the ability to consent
they're going to be used as commodities
for profit and it's not dissimilar to
the issue of child labor 100 years ago
where in theory it might be possible for
us to have children working in mass in
factories and sweat houses and so on and
producing good products for the people
in providing to their families but the
problem is anytime you put a powerless
class of beings into a system that is
driven by profit those beings will be
trampled on which is why I believe in
the abolition of animal exploitation but
I do want to make one important point
about veganism and vegetarianism you'll
notice that I didn't say much about
consumption or vegetarianism or veganism
in this talk and the the people I talked
about the billionaire is the homeless
person the horse who's you know probably
a vegetarian hopefully a vegetarian
although they do sometimes feed horses
and cows horse and cow me the solution
this problem is not going to come from
consumers making different choices
because what I hope that political
stress test showed you is that their
institutions that are designed around us
that drive us towards certain choices
and away from others right so the fact
that most people are not vegetarian has
a lot more to do with the fact that
McDonald's is a hundred billion dollar
company to the fact that the farm bill
gives twenty billion dollars plus and
subsidies to animal agriculture every
single year while many cases taking
money away from food stamps for kids to
the fact that when you look at the food
chain when you grow up as a kid everyone
is told from the day they're born
despite the fact that we have compelling
evidence otherwise that you have to eat
meat and dairy there are all these
institutional forces that are driving
people to consume animal products that
we need to overcome before we even start
with individual level outreach so this
is one thing that makes DXE very
different our focus is not on trying to
persuade individuals one by one that
they should go vegetarian or vegan we're
asking them whether they're vegetarian
or not to join the movement to stop
factory farming okay any other questions
or comments let me let me give someone
else a chance to talk followed with me
afterwards I just want to make sure
everyone gets some space any other
questions or comments
and the film that you showed in the
beginning of of what you were all doing
I think it might be beneficial to
explain that you were actually trying
you were you were protected by law was
that there was a law on the books that
protects animals from abuse and you were
saving them from the abuse and that is
completely legal and yet you were up
against those massive lines of police
and right here yeah yeah animal cruelty
is a crime and leaving an animal to
starve to death to be trampled to death
in a pen who's sick who's weak is also a
crime and you know this is not us saying
this we've worked with prosecutors
across the nation who agree with this
the problem is something called
prosecutorial discretion that most
people are not lawyers don't know about
which is that in fact most violations of
law are not ever prosecuted or enforced
you might intuitively know this because
you probably jaywalked has anyone
jaywalked in their own and you probably
haven't been prosecuted right because
the prosecutor has exercised discretion
there's actually many levels of
discretion there's the law enforcement
officer on the street who sees you
jaywalking and says okay this is not
deserving of a ticket or an arrest this
is just there's no cars there's no harm
I'll just let the person walk right and
the same is true unfortunately on the
level of animal cruelty and because
corporations have such immense influence
especially in the rural counties where
most of these factory farms exist
they're donating money to politicians or
funding campaigns they're going in and
out of the very regular Tory bodies that
are supposed to protect the animals and
the environment in consumers from the
violations of law that are happening in
factory farms most violations and
violations of industry endures to go
completely unacknowledged much less held
to account so what we have tried to do
is go into these factory farms find
clear violations of law get legal
opinions veterinary opinions showing
these are violations of law and these
are pretty egregious violations there
are things like using a carcinogenic
antibiotic feed for the animals things
like lying about corporate commitments
that have made to take animals out of
gestation crates things like leaving
animals to starve and dehydrated to
death to the point that one Costco egg
farm we
found close to 20 percent of the animals
literally in a starvation and
cannibalism conditions and these are
numbers the industry didn't even reject
we found the company's own record saying
that 20 percent of the animals had died
and that the most common reason they'd
all died was cannibals and they had been
pecking each other death inside the farm
and yet when we go and present these
findings to the authorities very often
instead of prosecuting the farmer and
the company they prosecute us what what
Susan is pointing out is there's a
doctrine of law that exists in the
English common law that whether there's
a statute or not many times we have
statutory protections whistleblower
protections for employees or activists
to identify some misconduct happening a
factory farm or frankly any corporate
abuser but there's also a doctrine of
law that infuses the English common law
system called legal necessity and both
the climate movement and lien rights
movement have now been using this
doctrine of law to justify direct action
against corporations engage in abuse so
this is what happened at Standing Rock
this is what happened at the White House
when Julian Bond among others arrests
chained himself to the White House gates
and said I have to do this because our
planet is burning and the idea my legal
necessity is when you've exhausted all
your legal avenues and you're doing
something that is clearly in the public
interest you have the right to engage in
otherwise unlawful behavior a classic
example is there's a dog in a hot car
normally you can't break somebody's
window but there's a dog in a hot car
you can see they're suffering from heat
exhaustion and they're dying you've
called the police there's no one around
who can help you can just go ahead and
break that window and take that dog to
the vet and we make the same argument
with respect to factory farms and the
misconduct we find in factory farms
whether that argument will prevail is up
to a jury in in my case in North
Carolina two juries in Utah and one jury
in California what we hope is that these
cases prevail it will open the
floodgates for activists like us to do
this sort of work across the world and
create a real crisis for the industry
including the fossil fuel industry
because in addition to being one of the
cofounders of direct action never I'm on
the board of the climate defense project
that has been defending the valve
Turner's does anyone know about the
valve Turner's okay so they're these
activists really great people like you
know ken ward an older gentleman retired
who is just sick of seeing the planet
burn and what he did all he did was he
win up to two kind of a I think it was a
refinery
and turned
valve they shut it off which caused all
sorts of you know collateral
consequences for the company cuz they
had you know all their business
basically stopped for a day but all he
did was turn the valve and he was
charged of felonies and what we don't
want to argue for climate actus and for
animal rights activists is when there's
a planetary emergency when there's some
individual victim who is about to die we
have the right to go in and try and
alleviate that harm if the government is
not going to act and if we win you know
that will not only open the floodgates
for more activism but put pressure on
our politicians to address these issues
more systematically yeah you know most
people probably think there's a bright
line X
yeah I'm curious how you came to feel
that that line was not as white as
you'll think and how how did you see
people in your movement finding that
line maybe softer I think it's the sort
of second layer of the question is you
know this theory of trickle up climate
justice that says that you know if
people are willing to do these things to
animals it relies on it makes them more
like that and protecting animals is a
first step toward protecting to engage
you know of course there are human
beings right now it's not a matter of
you know if one day they come for
immigrants or you know yeah we go folks
in China that's happening now do you
feel as though I know these are too
large questions but how do you deal with
this idea that there is a maturity cost
so the the answer the first question is
my dog like a lot of people I think the
the exception to the general rule in
human communities that people think
animals non-human animals are less
morally important than human animals is
their own companion animals and if you
look at kind of the amount of money that
the average dog Guardian or cat Guardian
spends on their animals in the United
States it's far more than they're giving
for the Bangladeshi child or even the
homeless person on the street they care
a lot about that individual animal so at
least with respect to this dog this cat
this rabbit this speciesism frontier has
been broached this person understands
this animal matters and for most people
if you ask them they're not doing it
just because they like the dog as a toy
the dog is interesting entertainment for
them they do conceive of that dog very
differently than a TV or a car vacation
to Disney Land they care about the dog
for their own sake one way you can tell
this is people leave money to their dogs
they're terrified about what's going to
happen in fact like you know pet
insurance life insurance for your pets
is a huge booming business because so
many older Americans are terrified that
my dog or cat could go to a shelter and
be euthanized if I die and she's still
alive so for most people when they think
about animals if there's an individual
in front of them they recognize that
this is a being that's worthy of some
social and political and moral
consideration the addendum I linked to
that point is that if you look at
polling data across the nation and
across the world public opinion is
changing very rapidly on animal issues
and the Gallup poll has done this poll
asking the public how many of you think
that animals should have the same rights
as human beings over the last 15 years
and it keeps going up and up and up and
up so if you ask people about 15 years
ago it was about one in five to up to
one in four Americans would say that
animals should have the same rights as
human beings now it's about one in three
and an even more recent poll that was
done by of all people an agricultural
economist show that one in two Americans
went to banned slaughterhouses in this
country now one in two americans are not
vegetarian or vegan but what that tells
you is that people see the future they
see the possibilities of a world where
we no longer have to slaughter animals
they neither they themselves are not
willing to make the commitment to give
up eating animals yet they want that to
happen they want to imagine a world
where animals no longer have to be
slaughtered well the environment no
longer has to be devastating they just
want us as politicians and elected
leaders to find those solutions so your
second question is is also a tough
question the first question I think is
actually an easier one because I think
public opinion is changing and I think
for many people actually have individual
experiences of animals you know and
frankly even people don't have
individual experiences of animals I
think I I read an article recently that
the most shared thing on facebook is
animal videos and if you don't believe
me go to the dodo Facebook page and look
at how many views their videos have and
compare that frankly to the NFL like
it's unbelievable that the dodo gets
more views on an average video than the
NFL doesn't you think the Superbowl is
big business go to the dodo but your
your second question is also an
important question because even if
animals are significant and have some
moral political value if they're we Gers
being confined in concentration camps in
in China if there are immigrants who are
being held in detainment facilities in
some cases being killed left to die on
the border with Mexico
can we talk about animals and and there
are a lot of people who will give you
kind of the cliched response which is oh
it all works together you know that we
can save them all and I don't think
that's true I think there are some
opportunity costs that have to be made
and the only point I'd make to you is
we're not even making a trade-off right
now when Bill Nordhaus the most famous
climate of Commerce in the world says
the value of all the millions species
that are going extinct all the trillions
are potentially quadrillions of animals
who are suffocating to death in the
oceans is where zero then we're just not
getting a
right we're not getting it right at all
because we've ignored that issue
entirely and that's what happens when a
community is completely politically
silenced that's what happened with
juveniles in the 18th century when they
started moving to the factories they
didn't have much political power and
even if you want to argue well you know
I worry about the kids in the factories
but we also have to worry about racism
right at least you're gonna have a
conversation about how we make that
trade-off right now what's happening is
there's no trade-off happening at all
because who folks were frankly even just
trying to give accurate information
about what's happening the animals are
too often being silenced so we have to
get animal rights into the political
discourse and then we can have those
tough conversations about opportunity
cost that frankly we have to have about
all of sheikhs you know health care and
immigration there's a trade-off there to
climate change in health care another
trade off we don't know what how we can
prioritize one over the other until we
start having that conversation and the
time to start having that conversation
about animals and climate justice is now
yeah a great new city idea what's the
best way to finance it would it be
issuing debt increasing Taxation private
investments I think in combination I
think what what I'm proposing is that
first and foremost we have to increase
taxation on folks to have mansions and
there's a way around the the property
tax law that I mentioned it's called
prop 13 that prevents you from raising
property taxes when home values increase
it's kind of a ridiculous thing that you
know someone who does not work and just
sits on their property and makes a
billion dollars out of it doesn't have
to pay a dime of taxes well the homeless
person is walking dogs pays 15% that
makes no sense what you can do is tax
things like vacancy you can't tax
property but if someone is not living in
their home we can impose a use tax and
say this home is empty
this is a basically a nuisance to the
community that we have this empty
mansion here when we have thousands of
people sitting on the streets and so
we're gonna charge you you know $1,000
an hour for that home to me empty unless
you start living in the home and I think
there are a lot of innovative taxation
schemes like this that economists are
coming up with that can get around the
constitutional concerns but in the day
you know a lot of those fights might be
they'll involve litigation because rich
people will fight them and say hey this
is de facto a property tax you're not
allowed to do that in California so we
probably will have to do things like go
into debt you know I think bond
offerings are important to do but if we
get this right if we actually make this
a green city if we have a green district
that is completely sustainable while the
roads are gone it's pedestrian-only
there are solar panels everywhere and
trees everywhere and we have a green
dividend and we're giving everyone
$1,000 so all the businesses coming in
tourism is coming in hopefully we get
private investment both in terms of
private consumption and tourism coming
into the city but also big green
companies like beyond meat and
impossible foods from I understand the
single biggest IPO in 2019 was beyond
meat a plant-based food company they
have billions of dollars and they know
that if we take some that business that
currently is going to climate destroying
animal abusing industries like factory
farms and give it to them that's going
to be a great stake for them financially
so we have to get them to join as
partners and I'm you know I totally hear
the critique the neoliberal critique of
trying to get these companies involved
but when we're near in an emergency
situation and when our planet is is
literally burning like our neighborhoods
are burning we have to get all hands on
deck including even factory farmers if
factory farmers are willing to
voluntarily give up and join this
movement let's let's let's not Sigma
ties and demonize them let's find a way
for them to transition and this is
already happening there been a number of
factory farms partly because of climate
change partly because of how owner is in
difficult it is to work with the big
corporations that really run everything
a lot of smaller scale contract farmers
who said I'm giving up the business and
I'm gonna start raising mushrooms
instead I'm gonna start growing soy
instead and we need to do that on mass
scale but we have to start in one city
but the most important thing is
regardless of how we do it if we know a
political leadership that's gonna have
that bold vision and say we don't have
time for this you know City of Berkeley
is one of the most aggressive climate
timelines that I've heard of of any
political or Geographic unit in the
United States of America and it's
timeline of 2035 is less aggressive than
Microsoft's and in our political system
is lagging behind even big corporations
like Microsoft and addressing the
climate crisis it should be the opposite
our political leadership needs a lead
which means engaging in these difficult
conversations and talking about
trade-offs and saying yes it is going to
suck to turn off all the natural gas
stoves in the City of Berkeley yes is
going to stuck for some people too
close off all our streets to cars and
build solar farms instead but we have a
bold beautiful vision of a city that's
sustainable it's gonna save your future
your kids future over the next
generation and even though it's going to
be sacrificed it's gonna be a beautiful
sacrifice because this vision is worth
it that's what our leadership needs to
do not make excuses not get defensive
not go to their donors and compromise
the the vision and the future that we
all need to share in but just be bold in
[Applause]
medical field and what your ideas about
that is Yale gets millions of dollars
every year yeah federal funding to do
sperimentale on animals happening now
and you know it's been shown that most
of the experiments are bogus and don't
prove anything in human disease yeah
yeah this is an example of our political
system disregarding the suffering of our
marginalized class of beings and
actually actively subsidizing the
cruelty right the estimates are anywhere
from maybe 10 200 million animals
probably not including fish and rodents
or using experiments every day and what
you're pointing to is a systemic failure
of animal cruelty laws because what we
do in theory have an animal alpha acting
you might think that the I think there
are even primates at Yale right or the
prime minister there even though you
might think that primates are Yale are
being protected by some federal or state
laws in fact on the Animal Welfare Act
which regulates experimentation any
procedure that is deemed scientifically
necessary by the investigator is allowed
no matter how cruel so you're not
allowed to just let your animal starve
if you if you put a monkey in a cage and
you know you leave for a month and the
monkey starves it up that's not allowed
on the internal wall frog but if I
decide you know what I want to find out
what happens when you rip monkeys arms
off and let them bleed to death I just
want to see what happens
that is totally kosher under federal law
right so this this is the nature of the
political system we live in today where
the other inhabitants of this earth are
treated with such cruelty and barbarism
that even if you intentionally
cruelty as long as you deem it
scientifically necessary it's totally
allowed I want to push back a little bit
on the scientific merits of some of
these studies because to me I don't even
want to get in that debate and I don't
know what the answer that is that's
that's a question for scientists to
answer but the main point is and it's
the same point I made to you we need to
start considering the animals at least
we need to think about whether they have
a stake in this system that we're
building and if they don't have a stake
why not what is it that allows us to
deny them some basic respect and
consideration and Yale is certainly part
of that problem thanks for the question
yeah yeah you maybe elaborate a bit more
on sort of long-term where you see your
animals fitting into legal and political
systems but I don't think the other
times you've mentioned the importance of
animal consent you mentioned equal
rights yeah - he wins I own a dog sounds
like you also have dogs yeah obviously
like the way even more benign
relationships are today it's like
there's more of a welfarist paradigm
than like you know extent animals the
same rights as humans like long-term
what kind of legal and political
standing do you think it's reasonable -
yeah it's a great question I think it's
so important for us to have that vision
because if we're gonna say we demand
animal rights we need to visualize what
that is so people understand what we're
actually asking for I think the best
work in this area has been done by will
kim luca who's a philosopher I think of
the University of Queens a list which is
imagining a world where we have embraced
trans-species justice but but I think
the basic idea with respect to
domesticated animals with respect to
wild animals I think for the most part
we should leave them alone I'm sensitive
the idea we should intervene in some
circumstances if there's a natural
disaster a disease outbreak the
Kitteridge fungus killing off you know
probably billions maybe trillions of
amphibians all over the world there's
something we do to solve the problem we
shop probably should try but human
beings don't have the greatest record of
intervening and natural systems to
protect other beings so you know
probably what we do with the wild
animals this first do no harm
domesticated animals live with us they
depend on us they have co-evolved with
us for thousands some cases possibly
tens of thousands a year so we can't do
that but the great thing is we already
have political institutions that are
designed to address situations like that
namely guardianship
right so when you look at kind of how
incapacity capacitated human beings and
young children are treated by the legal
system there's an entire set of legal
institutions of legal paradigms and even
case law that address how these beings
can still be visible to the law 150
years ago that wasn't true like a father
treated his child like a commodity and
that was okay but there's a move in this
country from juvenile justice for you
know child labor rights that created
some paradigms that we can now extend to
non-human animals so the scale of the
enterprise in many ways is numerically
larger because there are more non-human
animals in fact the most numerous
terrestrial vertebrate on this planet is
the domesticated chicken they're about
23 billion chickens alive on the earth
today which is way more human beings and
way more than any other land animal
exist so all these chickens need to be
treated with some legal paradigm but the
key thing is in terms of the complexity
in the nuance and the resources we'd
have to invest in creating guardianship
paradigms the chickens needs are not as
sophisticated as a human child's right
the chicken is never gonna need a right
to education it's not gonna probably
need a right to a sophisticated
healthcare as a human child because
chickens are actually fairly robust
species human children from the time
they're born because of how we evolved
they immediately need care they cannot
survive on their own that's not true of
a chicken that's not true of a lot of
these species that we've domesticated so
but the most important thing to do is
just start from the the place that we
already know and understand namely
juvenile justice dealing with people who
are mentally incapacitated and have a
guardian ad litem and it's sending that
to non-human animals and while there are
a lot of non-human animals now if we
just stop forcibly impregnating and
breeding these animals their populations
to decline by three four or five orders
of magnitude very quickly and I don't
think I'm not of the mindset that
someone like URI Franchione has which is
that domesticated animals need to
disappear I don't think that's the case
I think if we just allow them to to have
families just like us in a way that that
is consistent with good population
management guidelines they can coexist
with us for generations with no problem
I'm gonna give someone else who hasn't
talked a chance yeah go ahead yeah you
mentioned in the house motto caveat it's
if there's no value on non-human animals
yeah it may be like discounting future
Lopez also a copy automata I was
wondering where you see a room for
improvement in academic literature yeah
like what I pick should be yeah if I
knew the answer that question I would
have successfully completed my PhD and I
did I dropped out possible and in no
small part because I couldn't figure
this stuff out and it's it's hard
because you want to critique Nord
House's model but you're like well
what's what what's the alternative and
in one of the fundamental problems we're
seeing not just in this context but
frankly across human civilization is
what sort of metrics do we use that we
think money isn't the only measure of
value right this is something that David
Cameron pointed out ten years ago when
he said you know the UK needs to start
thinking about moving away from
maximizing gross domestic product and
maximizing gross happiness product me NC
Strickland the the founder of
Kickstarter everyone know Kickstarter
this cool
company that decided not to go public
I'm like every other tech company they
said we're not gonna go public we're
gonna become a B Corp instead where we
care about all our stakeholders we care
about our employees we care about the
local community we care about our
shareholders too but we care about
everybody and we don't want to be just
another one of those C courts that's
trying to maximize the financial returns
for investors but no one really knows
what that means because it's hard to
measure you know and and this is true in
many other domains alike I mean you know
Nancy Strickland points out to that
there's there's so much of domestic
labor that's not included women's labor
if you if there's a woman taking care of
her children there's no financial metric
that that measures the value that
contributes to society despite the fact
that hopefully all of us agree that
parents taking care of their children is
a huge and important contributor to
social value so my first answer that
question is that's a big problem that it
goes far beyond animal rights and I
don't know the answer to that question
my second answer to that question is
that is it is particularly important in
the context of animals because at least
in theory most these other domains of
human life and value you can imagine a
way to financially measure it like so
for example you could provide an
implicit cost to labor in the home and
and add that to GDP but the value that
animals contribute if you have a dog or
a cat
you know they're never gonna work for
your maybe they'll work for you about
bringing your paper but it's not a
material economic contribution to human
civilization what they're providing you
is more intangible goods things like
companionship love connection joy
counseling like my dogs are my best
counselors everyday but that's never
gonna be something we can finish Lee
Metro it's gonna be very hard for us to
financially matter so part of what the
enamel raishin movement needs to do and
part of what human civilization needs to
do is move away from these financial
metrics of well-being to other metrics
it actually reflect what we care about
because at the end of the day you know
Richard Easterlin pointed this out a
generation ago when you start hitting
five ten fifteen thousand dollars per
capita people don't get much happier
with more money you know it's it's more
money more problems and there's been
some research that's pushed back on that
a little bit but the general the general
thesis is still accurate that there's
massive diminishing marginal returns the
money and Jeff Bezos is not you know a
billion times happier than most of us
just because he has a billion times more
money in fact he might be a very sad he
seems like kind of a sad miserable
person so I feel sorry for him for
having all those billions
let's give someone else a chance to chat
and then let's why don't you answer it
afterwards I really encourage everyone
to connect but unless I'll come back to
you if no one else has anything to say
okay I didn't finish it
so I failed an economics NE mighte MIT
any other questions or comments yeah
yeah so what you said is I think we are
just another kind of animal and so
should we we should treat other animals
just like we treat ourselves just like
we want people to treat us and what's
your name Samantha thank you for
offering that Savannah is pointing out a
philosophical concept that Peter Singer
you know spent decades refining which is
the interchangeability of perspectives
right it doesn't matter whether you're a
black person a white person a gay person
a straight person a dog or a cat a human
or a rat that there's an
interchangeability of our perspectives
in our subjectivity that means we should
treat all these beings that can be
subjects of any sort of consciousness
with respect and if you doubt that
animals can be subjects of consciousness
cambrie's university i think in 2012
gathered a huge mass of all the world's
top neuroscientist and scholars of
cognitive scientists and and basically
asked them what do you think of animal
consciousness and there was an
overwhelming consensus about as high as
a consensus around anthropogenic human
caused climate change that animals at
least vertebrate animals are in fact
conscious so what you're saying is is
not just philosophically sound but is
scientifically based as well so thank
you for sharing that
and and we need and of course the
problem is as if so many things are
legal in our political systems are
lagging behind philosophic and
scientific understandings because our
legal system is a product of so much
path dependency in hundreds of years of
people fighting and lobbying of each
other to design the political system we
have today so our political system today
has to catch up and recognize that
non-human animals are sentient beings
deserving as some legal consideration
and if you want to read more about that
one of my former mentors and co-authors
Cass Sunstein wrote a book called animal
rights new directions I wrote a paper in
that book I think it's called animal
rights new directions and he has a a
paper within that edited volume called
standing for animals what does a legal
system look like that gives animals some
legal consideration because currently
animals are considered prop
how do we start conceiving of these
animals as something other than just
property for a company or a human being
to use and exploit you know the
questions and we have until 5:30 so and
I'll hang around here afterwards
let me give someone else a chance to ask
and in case someone else no one else and
please offer critiques like I love
challenging questions or even bring
together the subject of thinking
biodiversity to protect themselves when
they can't predict this kind of change
it's very challenging thank the
legislature for coming to talk today
enjoying their saw David David is one of
these bold young politicians who's who
sending aggressive climate timelines for
frankly our entire civilization but
David is also pointed is something that
I've experienced in 15 years of lobbying
work which is most legislators are
incredibly conservative and that's one
of the reasons they got where they got
because they were the popular kids
school and the popular kids school is
usually not the kid who goes out there
and takes chances that's why he's
popular because he does things that
everyone else is doing so we need to do
is put some unpopular kids into the prom
Mike David and and push the boundaries
I'm popular not in a bad sense you know
the unpopular kid in high school is the
cool kid 10 years later right like no
one know everyone who's cool at the age
of 35 everyone who's cool at the age of
35 probably wasn't that popular at the
age of 16 and and we just need to evolve
our legislative bodies in the same way
and recognize that just because someone
doesn't follow the formula the
democratic or the Republican Party is
set out for how we can solve climate
change for the past 20 years doesn't
mean they can't be a very important
voice within the legislature and that's
what we're seeing with a OC getting
elected you know beating an incumbent
who had been in Congress for 30 years in
the Bay Area we've had our first social
selected to the Board of Supervisors in
San Francisco so one of the is it 10
supervisors 11 supervisors one of the 10
or 11 most powerful people in the city
of San Francisco is now a socialist and
however you feel
about Democrats are socialists it tells
you that there's something revolutionary
in the zeitgeist in our country today
people are sick and tired of politics is
unusual and want something different
which is why it's so great to have you
in the cop in the Connecticut
legislature so thank you
you're stepping up yeah thanks
aggressive so maybe one more question
and then I think we're done cuz it's
almost 5:30 all right question if no one
who hasn't spoken once to speak we can
go back to you know one new guy this
little girl said she cut right to the
chase
and it's really as simple it's really
simple and I think it's value space we
have to start working at changing her
values as as a culture yeah worldwide
and that just hit them she hit the nail
on the head and maybe it's bringing in
faith-based communities in order to
start changing perceptions as to what
what defines success in life it's not
cap it's not money no it's not riches
it's it's love no and just kudos to
thank you Savannah indeed it's not money
it's not riches its life that's a great
way to end the talk so thank you all for
coming
if you want to hang out a bit I'm gonna
hang out for a little while I think some
students and I are going out to dinner
at a place called Claire's I don't think
you can join our table necessarily but
if you want to come to Claire's with us
I have no problem as long as the
students don't have a problem and we can
all hang out how some food and then John
do you want to please do that and come
talk to me if you'd like to check okay
thanks everybody
[Applause]
[Music]